auf dem mond ist eine riesige höhle
gefunden worden jetzt als idealer
standort für eine mondstation
identifiziert wurde die auswertung der
daten der mondsonde selene und der grail
raumsonden und die verknüpfung der daten
brachte wirklich erstaunliche ergebnisse
zu tage
und diese welle bricht sämtliche höhen
rekorde hier auf der erde
warum sie so außergewöhnlich ist und der
perfekte standort für eine mondstation
und absolut riesig wirklich riesig also
wie ist die lage auf dem mond jetzt in
klicks um science-fiction herzlich
willkommen der mode ist für den längeren
aufenthalt von menschen eigentlich
überhaupt nicht geeignet er hat keine
atmosphäre und verfügt auch nicht über
ein magnetfeld astronauten und
astronautinnen sind der kosmischen
strahlung dort ungeschützt ausgesetzt
zudem gibt es auf der oberfläche extreme
temperaturunterschiede zwischen tag und
nacht ein absolut unwirtlicher ort eine
atmosphäre können wir dort nicht
herstellen wir müssen eine luftdichte
mondstation bauen allerdings könnten die
astronauten auf verlauten vor den hohen
temperaturen geschützt werden wenn die
station geschützt lege und auch die
kosmische strahlung könnte von dem teams
abgehalten werden wenn die station eben
geschützt wäre und jetzt scheint der
ultimative schutz gefunden worden zu
sein
schon seit langem vermuten
forschungsteams unter der mondoberfläche
lover sie entdeckten jetzt ein
sogenanntes skylight ein loch in einer
höhlendecke durchmesser 50 meter es
sieht aus wie ein krater ist es aber
nicht sondern eben eine öffnung nach
oben in einer riesigen höhle eben ein
skyler die japanische sonde selena hat
sich jetzt entdeckt in der region marios
hills im ozean der stürme stieß ich auf
eine auffällige struktur unter der
mondoberfläche das rada empfing ein
doppeltes echo ein hohlraum unter der
mondoberfläche war gefunden worden james
von der pew university wertete daraufhin
die schwerfällt daten der grail
raumsonden der region aus und machte die
sensation perfekt unter der
mondoberfläche befindet sich eine höhle
achtung festhalten mit einer länge von
50 kilometern höhe und einer breite von
jeweils einem kilometer da passt
die komplette großstadt rein und eine
mondstation sowieso der absolute
wahnsinn es wird spannend wie diese
höhle jetzt erforscht wird und wie darin
dann eine mondstation gebaut wird wenn
er kein video zu diesem thema verpassen
wollt und zu allen anderen themen dann
drücken wir hier ein abo aufs auge und
vergesst nicht den genau auf die glocke
denn nur dann werdet ihr informiert wenn
es ein neues video hier gibt und hier
geht es weiter mit helium-3 abbau auf
dem mond china als erster ich kann nur
sagen der wettlauf zur besiedlung und
der nutzung des mohns hat begonnen es
bleibt spannend bis dann bleibt dran